مره اخرى تكشف الشرطه لندن عن المجرمين في
صفوفها ويرتدي زيها وتعترف بانها اتجاهل
التحذيرات ارتكابه الجرائم
لقد خدنا لندن
وما فعله بضحاياه امر بسيط حقا وشجاعه
الابلاغ عنه امر مثير للاعجاب
ضابط الشرطه لمده 18 عاما النساء
المستضعفات وارتكب جرائم بحقهن واعترف
كاريك امام المحكمه ب 94 منها 24 حاله
اغتصاب طالت اثنا عشر سيده ضحاياه شعارنا
بانه لا يمكننهن التقدم بشكوى ضد في وقت
مبكر لانه قال لهن لا احد سيصدقهن هذه
الفضيحه شوهت سمعه الشرطه ومصداقيه الناس
فيها مضاربه
النساء بالشرطه
ليس لدي اي ثقه في جهاز الشرطه خصوصا وان
شرطيا حاولت تقرب مني بهذه الطريقه عندما
كنت في شبابي انبي
فضيحه الشرطه ارغمت الداخليه على تقديم
احاطه الى النواب
يمكنني
لن تخجل من تحدي الشرطه للوفاء بالمعايير
التي نتوقعها جميعا التغيير يجب ان يحدث
هو بصفه وزيره الداخليه سافعل كل ما في
وسعي لضمان ذلك
بانتظار يصطاد حكم مدتي سجنه طردت ضبط من
الشرطه التي تعرضت للكافرين من الانتقادات
لسلوك عناصرها في السنوات الاخيره اطاحت
برئيستها السابقه هذا الضابط المدن ليس
الاول الذي ارتكب جرائمه وهو يعمل في جهاز
الشرطه ولن يكون الاخير مع تاكيد رئيس
مفوضيه شرطه العاصمه انه هناك العشرات من
اعضائه يخضعون للتحقيق بشان ما زعم سوء
سلوك الجنسي او العنصريه مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن